big news for the white race this morning
according to new Census Data white
people are officially finished as the
majority race in America
until 1965 white people made up about 85
percent of the U.S population then a new
Mass migration policy along with a
collapse in native born American birth
rates combined to drop that percentage
down to the 60 or so percent that it is
today and now according to a new
analysis gen Z will officially be the
last majority white American generation
as the youngest generation gen Alpha has
already seen white people replaced as
the majority population
now if you are white you cannot mention
this fact if you were to observe this
demographic model especially if you did
so with any even slight hint of
reservation
you would of course be a racist
conspiracy theorist but other people
such as the liberal media they are
permitted to observe it especially if
they celebrate it so here we have it
I'm not all that worried the Sicilians
have always been a racially ambiguous
people I'm sure that my swarthy skin
will fare just fine in America's beige
future I can easily pass for Hispanic
when I hold my sitar I've been mistaken
for Indian in particularly hot summers I
look downright North African so I'm not
losing sleep
but given my slightly dustier complexion
is it all right if I suggest even meekly
that perhaps there's something just a
little bit sad about a nation's founding
stock passing away
if I suggest that maybe white people
aren't intrinsically evil and deserving
of demographic Doom is that the sort of
thing that's going to get me canceled
it wouldn't get me canceled if we were
discussing pretty much any other country
on Earth certainly any country outside
the West
if let's say over the course of 60 years
Japan opened its borders and the
Japanese became a minority in Japan
wouldn't lots of people wonder at that
maybe even worry a little bit if the
Nigerians suddenly became a minority in
Nigeria after an influx of Icelandic
immigrants
wouldn't people
I'm not saying it would be a bad thing
okay I'm just
wouldn't it be a cause for concern
for a lot of people for at least the
Nigerians who might fear that such a
massive influx of newcomers might
displace or even erase their customs and
their way of life
are we allowed to raise any of those
questions or are we just supposed to
deny that any of those concerns are even
a possibility
until they become an inevitability to
celebrate
I'm Michael olses the Michael Knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get
great meat at a secure price and 30
bucks off your order with my code
Knowles go to goodranchers.com use my
code Knowles today I had good Rancher
steak two nights ago and it was just so
delicious it was so good I can't even
express it in words
there is some breaking news about porn
which is that PornHub is now going dark
in Arkansas because it is so insistent
on not making sure that little kids look
at their stuff and we'll get to that
story in just a second first though
when I want to stay on the topic of
getting canceled for a second
because Neo Neo
a rapper
n-e-y-o I think it's Neo
he
said a thing
got canceled
apologized
unapologized
and it so now we're in a good spot where
I'm very pro-neo again I lost track
somewhere in the neopath along the way
but what here's what Neo
said that got him canceled
[Music]
speaking of reasoned arguments speaking
of getting canceled
a Seattle Times editorial board member
has been fired
for defending Hitler
can you imagine this guy defended Hitler
it's especially weird that he defended
Hitler because his family was targeted
by Nazi Germany
but he defended Hitler according to the
libs and so he was fired for that what
did he actually do
well
there's a statue in Seattle of Vladimir
Lenin one of the worst men in modern
history and
this Seattle Times editorial board
member pointed out that Lenin was sort
of a bad fellow too and you're not
allowed to do that in our modern culture
we'll get to why in just a second first
though when you see things falling
around around you probably
that is a good
encouragement to pray which is why you
gotta check out hallow right now go to
hallow.com it is clear that the libs are
giving up their morals in any Common
Sense there's no better time to build a
daily habit of prayer and meditation
building a habit of prayer can help you
cultivate an attitude of gratitude
focusing on what you are thankful for
can increase positive emotions and
improve overall well-being hallow is the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
United States it's helped many maintain
a daily prayer routine and it can help
you too download the app for free at
hallow.com Knowles you can set prayer
reminders and track your progress along
the way not sure where to start check
out father Mike schmitz's Bible in a
year available on the Hello app for
brief daily readings and Reflections or
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel and even some world-class
athletes with hallow you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
listen wherever you are with
downloadable offline sessions using Halo
to connect with others who share your
beliefs and values can provide a sense
of belonging support and Foster a sense
of community also you have an obligation
to your God to pray don't forget that
helps you but you have an obligation
okay so make sure you go check it out
right now hello go to hello.com get an
exclusive three months free that's three
months absolutely free at hallow.com
Knowles
there's this Lenin statue in Seattle I
didn't realize there's a statue of Lenin
not John Lennon that would be bad enough
but Vladimir Lenin in Seattle American
city this big giant Russian Kami statue
and there's this journalist who is a
Seattle Times editorial board member and
he said
look Hitler's very bad we view Hitler as
the worst guy ever but Lenin was was
pretty bad too there were other bad
people also and he pointed out quote in
fact while Hitler has become the great
symbol of evil in history books he too
was less evil than Lenin because Hitler
only targeted people he personally
believed were harmful to society whereas
Lenin targeted even those he himself
didn't believe were harmful in any way
that's a tweet that velazco this this uh
David Joseph velazco the senatorial
board member sent out then he deleted it
you're not allowed you cannot say
that anyone was more evil or even as
evil or even anywhere near as evil as
Hitler
even if that person is even even if
you're saying that Hitler was evil and
even if you're saying that there are
multiple other evil people you can't
you're not allowed to do that
so he deletes this tweet
then he writes out he tries to correct
it he says Hitler was more evil than
Lenin if we're looking at what they did
to people and that's a pretty important
metric for assessing evil so now he's
just spinning I don't even know what
he's trying to say
and he's fired now and he'll be canceled
for that but why
why
Lenin certainly led to the death of more
people than Hitler did
uh Lenin's ideology it was certainly at
least as evil as Hitler's ideology Lenin
especially taken
uh in in the context of his successor
Stalin
not only killed as many if not more
people but did so in very similar ways
at basically the same time
why why is it that
Hitler is the only evil person in
history and other evil men like Lenin
and Stalin you're not you're not even
allowed to to mention their evil actions
well there's a simple enough answer
which is that
Lenin through his successor Stalin
won World War II
and Hitler Lost World War II
that's why because we were on we had a
pact with the Russians the Russians
initially had a pact with Hitler that
was back when the Russians were very bad
people but then the Russians made a pact
with us and then they became really good
people
and Russia won so Russia's the good guy
Uncle Joe Stalin he's a good guy
now had it turned out differently you'd
have a very different history and it
turned out differently
you would hear a total downplay let's
say let's say the axis won World War II
you would have a total downplaying of
the Holocaust and all the other horrors
of World War II and instead what you
would have is a major focus on the
holodomor you would have a major focus
on Stalin's genocide in in Ukraine which
killed historians previously at
estimated between 7 and 10 million
people some have revised that number
down to five and six million people but
still whatever we're talking about
a lot of people very very serious amount
of Bloodshed that would be the big Focus
and you'd hear all sorts of criticisms
of America had had we lost the war all
sorts of criticisms of Great Britain and
a downplaying of the atrocities of Nazi
Germany
that's just the way it works it gets
back to this old line from Norm
Macdonald which is uh he said oh you
know I'm reading in this history book
here this is an amazing fact about
history uh you know the good guys have
won every single War ever
and people shouldn't misinterpret his
joke
because the the joke is not that the
good guys get defeated the joke is about
how the the victors write their own
history and what they do is they they
downplay all of their own atrocities
so you you actually can I mean this
maybe this guy just fell for some
political naivete here this Seattle
Times editorial board member
but
Lenin and Stalin won
and so we're in the political order
where the victors can't really be
criticized all that much yeah at the
time I mean you had goodness gracious
you had the the American Press carrying
water for these communities awful
communists
but that's the way it works you're only
allowed to point out the atrocities of
the losers
and if you you think that you can take
some objective position
say no Hitler very very bad Lenin very
very bad Stalin very very bad no that's
not the way it works that's not the
political order that we're living in the
political order is structured by The
Victors and the Seattle Times editorial
board member learned it the hard way
now speaking of History
Barack Obama
might be
a little bit light in the loafers
this is breaking news and it's not from
some tabloid and it's not from some Far
Right Kook it's from David Garrow who is
a very very serious biographer he is
biographer of Barack Obama there have
been a number of biographies written of
Obama that are cheap kind of hit jobs
that's not what this guy does this guy's
a Pulitzer prize-winning historian and
biographer he won the Pulitzer all the
way back in 1987. he's not considered a
far-right conservative by any means and
David Garrow is is now working on what I
suppose will be the sort of
authoritative biography of Obama and he
has discovered that Obama wrote letters
to a girlfriend when he was at
Occidental College which is the college
he went to before he transferred to
Colombia
and he
apparently expressed his desire to do
all sorts of strange things with men
according to Garrow with Alex McNair who
is Obama's girlfriend
I think she wanted to have her role
known so when Alex showed me the letters
from Barack she redacted one paragraph
in one of them and just said it's about
homosexuality
why did Garrow start pushing why is this
coming out now I don't think it's coming
out now because it's a it's an attack on
Obama I mean I think this woman probably
still likes Obama but now we're past the
Obama presidency he's not going to lose
an election or anything and they just
want the story to come out and what Gara
realized is something that I realized
when I was reading Barack Obama's first
Memoir he wrote a couple and it's
something that you may have noticed too
when you read dreams from my Father
which is that it's a work of fiction and
Obama even admitted it was a work of
fiction he'd write about a girlfriend in
dreams from my father and the girl never
existed and he would admit she never
existed and when he got caught on this
issue this lie he said well she's a
composite she's a composite character of
different women I'd met in my life
composite characters so you're telling
me your Memoir is a work of fiction and
we knew that because so much of Barack
Obama's actual biography did not line up
with reality I think this is one of the
things that fueled the the birther idea
that he wasn't really born in Hawaii or
something that wasn't just some crazy
kooky idea that a bunch of mean nasty
people thought about nowhere it's
because Barack Obama had lied about so
much of his biography the story kept
changing one of his Publishers actually
wrote on the book jacket of one of his
books that he was born in Kenya but even
let's say that was just an accident so
much of his biography in his own pen in
his own writing was fiction and so now
this biographer says okay Barack Obama
you know a little bit uh a big musical
theater fan let's say you know what does
this mean for him I have a little bit of
a different take than a lot of the
conservatives do but first when you want
to look good you don't want to just
rewrite your Memoirs and lie about your
past if you want to look good you got to
just use genucel right now go to
geniusell.com Knowles that dark spot on
your face is it still bothering you what
about all those sunspots all over your
body now you can watch them disappear
safely and quickly in three quick
minutes Jenny sells dark spot luxury
system does exactly what it sounds like
by using the world famous
microdermabrasion before the Dark Spot
Corrector you will see the dark spots
disappear before your very eyes
instantly smoothly and luxuriously
you'll be amazed at how quick you'll see
results are 100 of your money back
guaranteed go to genucell.com Knowles
right now to order the new dark spot
treatment system today say goodbye to
those pesky dark spots tomorrow that is
geniusell.com
right now save over 70 off geniusell's
most popular package that includes this
dark spot system I love geniusell I
especially love the founder who's a
Coptic Christian from Egypt who fled
Egypt for the American dream and has a
great company with a great product go to
genucel.com k-n-o-w-l-e-s
it's here folks enjoy an all new episode
of my beloved and wildly controversial
interview game show yes or no in this
latest episode I'm joined by the mother
of my God child and daily wears resident
Firebrand The One and Only Love Like
Candace Owens
Candace brought her Unapologetic hot
takes to the table to make this a very
exciting episode you don't want to miss
check out this clip
men who don't work out are like women
who cry on Tick Tock after their pet
bunny dies it's disordered weak and hard
to look at
just funny
[Music]
don't forget you can bring the show home
yes or no the game is back in stock it
always sells out and sells out fast so
if you want it I'd order it right now go
to dailywire.com shop to get yours with
200 cards and the ability to play up to
nine people at once it is easy to see
why this is the best selling and most
important game important game at Daily
wire I think it's the number one merch
that we're selling yes or no is hands
down the best way to add some excitement
to your parties challenge your friends
and Family's knowledge and delve into
the most thought-provoking topics of our
time daily wire.com shop order yes or no
today
I have a hot take on this Revelation
from Obama's biographer that he had
homosexual fantasies and wrote about
them to his girlfriend
huh
that's my hot take I had to exam
the main conservative hot take I'm
seeing is sees uh finok you know he's
lighting the loafers and I think I don't
know maybe yeah he clearly he obviously
had these fantasies and wrote about them
to his girlfriend
and and then what
people are saying haha see this proves
it ah he's a hypocrator I don't know
what
what's the guy supposed to do
I I'm just viewing this from the
perspective of a social conservative
who when asked about this issue people
will write in or they'll they'll show up
they'll say look I have a same-sex
attraction what am I supposed to do and
the liberal culture says well you should
just embrace it put on some leather go
to Greenwich Village you know go to a
bath house somewhere live your best life
baby go to a pride monkey box party or
something that's going to be the way to
flourishing and the social conservatives
have said
well no you should just suppress or
sublimate that desire and not indulge it
and this this is always a little bit of
a hard line because you think well easy
for you to say I mean
everybody has certain disordered desires
and affections but that one's got to be
pretty hard right I think it's very easy
for us especially those of us who are
socially conservative to say hey look we
don't have to deal with this issue so
yeah sorry we like girls so we can you
know have an ex a full expression of our
sexual desires and you can't do that so
yeah tough tough suck it up you know
okay it's very easy it's a very hard
saying I think for people who have to
deal with this so I think I don't know
what do we what do we want the guy to do
he had these desires
he didn't I don't know maybe indulged in
them but it seems like he didn't and
then he got married and had kids and
lived a basically normal life and he
said even if he had these desires he
said no I'd rather have a family I'd
rather maybe he's just said I'd rather
have a successful political career or
maybe have this that or the other thing
isn't it isn't that what we want people
to do I just think if if social
conservatives pounce on these guys and
kind of mock them and then
we're not giving anyone an out so much
of this modern culture I think
the modern liberal culture that says
indulge all of your appetites it it
preys on society not giving people an
off ramp not giving people an
alternative
if someone has a or something like that
what are they supposed to do I think
this is why I think social conservatives
should speak compassionately about them
and if if Barack Obama is expressing
some shame or some desire to cover this
up according to David Garrow he's not
being given access to a number of Barack
Obama's personal papers
probably for this reason I think I'm
good on him
good on him for feeling some compunction
about this and not wanting this fact to
come out all about it all about it man
that's the only nice thing I'll say
about Barack Obama ever speaking of
weird sex stuff Jill Biden has met with
some
[Music]
speaking of weird sex stuff there's a
lot there's a lot today this is this is
my giving Media Matters lots of clips
for the week kind of day we're opening
on Race then we're getting to Hitler
then we're getting to the weird sex
stuff so this is a smorgasbord maybe
I'll take it easy the rest of the week
but there is some really good news
coming out of Arkansas
Arkansas right now has passed a law
saying that if you want to Peddle smut
and pornography in the state you got to
make sure that you're not peddling it
directly to children
seems reasonable enough I think probably
you could have gotten to that end by
just enforcing obscenity laws that are
already on the books but because we've
got squishy liberal judges in recent
decades Arkansas says okay we want to be
very clear especially with the
technological change of the internet
we're going to be very clear you can't
Target smut directly to Children there's
got to be about one step
in between the kids and the porn and
PornHub said
okay we're not doing business in
Arkansas anymore
PornHub said that in Arkansas it said
that in multiple other states now as
other states have pushed for any even
the most
basic regulations of pornography the
kind of Regulation that used to exist at
newsstands if someone went in wanted to
buy a Playboy the Playboy would be
covered in a special
material so that you couldn't just see
all the stuff on the cover right away
and you'd have to ask it was behind the
counter you'd have to be kind of
embarrassed and ask
basic stuff so that kids couldn't get at
it at a Playboy what's on the Internet
is a lot worse than what was in Playboy
and Penthouse decades ago
PornHub says no thanks if I can't peddle
this directly to Children I'm just going
to stop doing business in the whole
state
that tells you everything that you need
to know about the pornography industry
the whole pornography industry is about
children
it's not just a little bit of it it's
the whole thing
we focus on these particularly
sensationalist and hideous examples
the sort of thing that sound of freedom
is based on child exploitation child
pornography we talked about that a
little bit yesterday the whole industry
is based on kids because the whole
industry is based on hooking kids when
they're very young the median age of
exposure to porn is something like 11
years old now might even be younger at
this point that might be an outdated
statistic so you hook them when they're
very young and then you melt their
brains and you get these kids whose
brains are very spongy you get them
addicted to pornography and then they
can never break it that's why PornHub
won't risk this
the reason that PornHub is giving is to
why they won't risk this is they're
saying well our users value privacy so
they're not going to want to submit a
photo of an ID
to prove that they are over 18 because
then
we're going to know who they are and
what they're looking at
I don't think that's the slam dunk
argument that PornHub thinks it is why
are people reticent to to reveal their
identities when they're looking at
pornography because it's filthy and
shameful and degrading and makes people
look like perverts and so they don't
want to admit when when they can look at
it in anonymity or supposed anonymity
someone's always watching buddy but when
they're when they can at least fool
themselves into thinking that they're
Anonymous and nobody's watching then
they'll watch it but the moment that
they have to acknowledge it they're
going to they're going to stop it
so there's those two reasons but don't
downplay the the targeting of kids if
you ever complained about tobacco
companies cigarette companies targeting
kids with advertising in the 90s which
every liberal did then
I'd sure like to hear you speak up about
pornography because big porn makes the
big tobacco companies look like Child's
Play look like the amateur league in the
way that they target children with their
smut
so what are we going to do about it
what would I do if I If I Were King of
Arkansas
I don't know Arkansas is doing a great
job you know Sarah Sanders I love her
but what would I do if I were the
governor of a state right now how would
you well I would pass this kind of a law
and
how would I then try to enforce it or
put it into practice
I guess I would just
enforce obscenity laws I would I
wouldn't even necessarily need to pass
new laws I would just enforce the
obscenity laws already on the books and
I'd go after these guys they provide
absolutely no benefit to society they
provide a lot of harms to society they
screw up a lot of people's lives and so
I just
I'd I'd ban it all or I'd enforce the
pre-existing bands and if they continue
to violate it I would arrest the
Distributors and I wouldn't just go
after low level guys this is where I
think people are being a little unfair
to Andrew Tate
this is where I'm going to come in I'm
not exactly defending Andrew Tate here
but I'm pointing out
it's fine to have righteous indignation
about Andrew Tate doing all sorts of
nasty pimpy things and seducing women
and putting them on webcam that yeah
it's awful
Small Potatoes guys
if you're if you're against that if
you're for imprisoning Andrew Tate then
you should be 100 times 1 000 times more
in favor of imprisoning the head of Mind
geek which is the parent company of
PornHub you should be one thousand times
in favor of imprisoning the owners of
only fans and all of the other
porn sites
okay if you're if you're going to go
after the Small Potatoes because Andrew
Tate is particularly obnoxious on video
or something he makes a good cartoon
character villain okay fine but go after
the big guys don't just focus on little
Andrew Tate
go after the big guys otherwise it seems
that one is disingenuous
on uh or incoherent in one's view of
this now when you want to be coherent
when you want to be virile when you want
to be strong and energetic and satisfied
with your meals you got to check out
good ranchers right now go to
goodranchors.com use promo code Knowles
I adore good ranchers I absolutely love
it their food is absolutely fabulous I
eat it multiple times a week very often
the stakes are excellent they've turned
me into a rib eye guy their burgers are
the absolute best burgers I've ever had
in my life they now have a pork box
they now have a pork box that was my one
complaint I said I want some nice juicy
brats or something and then they did it
they they did that right now good
ranchers is the only meat company
locking in your price right now they've
got their industry first price lock
guarantee since 2021 they've been
helping people combat the inflation of
the meat aisle as well as the mystery of
it too turns out over 85 of grass-fed
beef is imported from overseas so not
only the store-bought meat expensive
it's a often low foreign quality also
subscribe to good ranchers right now get
that price lock guarantee I don't know
how they're doing it especially with
inflation but it's just terrific
goodranches.com use code Knowles for 30
bucks off any box promo code Knowles
Canada goodranchors.com goodranchors.com
American Meat delivered
you know when Dr Jordan B Peterson made
the decision to join daily wire plus it
was a major win for those who Champion
free speech and intellectual debate with
one year of unparalleled output his
contributions set new standards and
remain unmatched by any other platform
daily wire plus now has a vast array of
exclusive Jordan Peterson content
offering hundreds of hours of
captivating content you won't find
anywhere else Jordan has created
thought-provoking works that reshape
your perspective on life which include
vision and Destiny marriage and Dragons
monsters and men Additionally you can
immerse yourself in discussions that
nurture your spiritual side such as
logos and literacy Jordan's new series
on Exodus I haven't even mentioned his
Beyond order lecture series or his
extensive Archive of lectures and
podcasts plus there is even more new
exclusive content on the Horizon by
becoming a daily wire plus member you'll
embark on an unforgettable experience
that will fuel your thirst for knowledge
and Inspire personal growth like never
before go to dailywire.com subscribe to
become a member today my favorite
comment yesterday is from chasney 1915
Who Says Megan rapino only represents
herself not our country she will always
be known as an anti-American player who
missed the shot and everyone cheered
that's true and it's not totally her
fault though it's because she's a
liberal
because liberalism
it's not just Megan rapino it's not just
the woke the woke people it's not just
the extreme far or left Fringe it's
liberalism liberalism encourages
individualism above all other
considerations even people on the right
will sometimes do that certainly the
Libertarians it's the whole liberal
ideology that has pervaded our entire
civilization that says unchosen
commitments family country
religion uh community
all the those that's nothing
forget about those
all that matters is your individual
expression that's the most important
thing in the world and you'll hear
people on the right not as often as
people on the left wheel or some people
on the right say that too the rapino
problem
oddly enough is representative of an
American police the only way in which
Megan rapino does represent the United
States
okay this brings me to our old Pals
at Harry's razors
Aries razors
there's a new ad out
they're leaning in
promoting their razors for
[Music]
I think women are getting fed up with
this birthing parent stuff though
being kicked to the sidelines I think
women are getting fed up with feminism
and the sexual Revolution more broadly
Kelly Osborne Ozzy Osbourne's daughter
was just asked why there are no pictures
of her when she was pregnant and people
asked if it was because she had a
surrogate carry her child and she's
denying that I don't know whether she
did or not but she's denying that she
had a surrogate she's saying no I hid
you won't find any pictures of me at all
during pregnancy I hit all nine months
of pregnancy to avoid being fat shamed
because I've been a public figure all my
life and I just didn't want to be on
camera fat
I don't know whether that explanation is
true or not
it at least Rings true and at least
Rings plausible Lindsay Lohan just came
out she said being pregnant is the
greatest joy of my life
Lindsay Lyons had a pretty pretty fun
Wildlife she says being pregnant being a
mother it's the greatest joy of my
entire life Khloe Kardashian do you
remember that clip of Khloe Kardashian
just coming out saying man surrogacy was
a horrible idea I wish I carried my
child
the surrogate process Kim knows it's
really hard for me
what was that mean she had a really hard
time accepting the whole process got it
it's a mine it's really the worst I do
think that there is a difference when
the baby is in your belly
the baby actually feels your real heart
think about it it like touches your org
like it's feel there's no one else on
this planet that will feel you from the
inside like that like your heart you
know I felt really guilty that like this
woman just had my baby and you're just I
take the baby and then I go to another
room and you're sort of separated like I
felt it's such a transactional
experience because it's not about him
so true I wish someone was honest about
surrogacy
it's just very different
I wish someone was honest about
surrogacy that's a great line
she says there's this woman bleeding in
the other room you know and then I'm
there and it's not about the baby it's
just a transaction it's an economic
transaction
we've we've reduced the relation between
men and women one of the great joys of
life
into
an interchangeable commercial Enterprise
even the language we use we talk about
our partner now we don't say our my wife
my husband my boyfriend we see my
partner
like it's an accounting firm and it's
not just the men who are waking up to
this it's the women
the women who were saying huh
I don't want to be treated like a
commodity to be used up and thrown out
when I'm no longer valuable to people
I don't want to buy my child
and I want to be a non-descript not
birthing parent
I'm a woman I'm a woman hear me roar
this this is why women are becoming more
Trad there's this this trend
it was a little early to the trend we
were doing this before it was cool
of Trad wives and people looking at a
more traditional kind of culture
you're seeing this among former liberals
who recognize that liberalism is crazy
they're shifting to the bright and
you're seeing this among people who
would have called themselves libertarian
who are becoming actual conservatives
now huge numbers of them including
prominent ones
and large numbers of non-prominant ones
who usually have better intuition than
the prominent ones
it's a recognition that it's it's a
little weird in our culture that
pregnancy is shamed that being a woman
being a real woman not just a pretend
man is shamed
that being normal is shamed
there's a recognition that at the very
least Satan we're not saying anything
about the wonderful achievements of
progress but we're just saying
it's a little bit weird
what's going on in this country it's a
little strange it's a little strange
that the first lady's posing for photos
with a bunch of it's a little odd isn't
it and maybe we need to pull at that
thread and figure out why is that why
how did we get here and as people are
doing it it's not just far right
conservatives it's ordinary people and
it's a lot of ordinary women start
pulling at that thread they realize that
we have to undo Decades of error C.S
Lewis made this point he said when
you're walking down the road the true
Progressive because everyone wants to be
a progressive now the true Progressive
is the person who realizes when you're
walking down the wrong road you're the
you turn around first and you start
going back the way you came that's the
true Progressive rather than keep going
all the way to Oblivion the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code
knowleskin at wbles at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign